JEN TONG: So I'm going to
be talking to you today
about prototyping with
Node.js and Firebase.
IOT prototyping of course,
because hence the conference.
Before I get into
that, let me tell you
a little bit about myself.
Hi, I'm Jen.
I'm a developer
advocate, which means
I get to come to
events like this
and I get to help all of
you build really cool stuff.
That's what this talk is about.
My focus is primarily on
Google Cloud Platform,
so I guess the internet part
of that Internet Of Things.
And I always love
hearing from all of you,
whether it's
questions about APIs
or you just want to share
something cool that you've
been building.
So as always feel free
to hit me up on Twitter.
I'm @MimmingCodes.
I'd love to hear
from all of you.
So before I dig into my
stuff, let me ask all of you
some questions.
First of all, how
many of you are
professional
electrical engineers?
OK, I'm just going to apologize
to all of you right now.
I'm going to make a lot
about the simplifications
and a lot of generalizations.
We can talk about it later.
But for now, just roll with it.
How many of you know
JavaScript better than C?
That's what I like to hear,
because there's coding the talk
and it's all JavaScript.
This is all about
using what you have
and doing cool stuff with it.
How many of you have like a
Raspberry Pi or an Arduino
Uno that's at your
house sitting on a shelf
somewhere gathering
dust all lonely?
You had great plans to do
something awesome with it
and it just like sat?
OK.
This talk is all about using
the skills and those boards you
already have including the
Edison in other boards you
may have gotten recently,
and doing cool stuff with it.
So let's dig in.
And here's my plan.
First, I'm going to
talk a little bit
about electrical
engineering stuff
and kind of the context
targeting at people with mainly
a web development background.
Then, I'm going to kind
of switch over and talk
about a recipe for IOT.
This is my personal
favorite recipe
for a very specific
use case, a recipe
for building one of something.
So it's like the
bill of materials
has got a little
more than something
you'd put in production.
It uses a little more
batteries than you
could if you optimize
it, but it has the upside
of being super easy to use.
And you can get something
working right away
and focus on making
a thing awesome.
Then I'm going to prove to all
of you it is actually easy.
I'm Going to show you that by
actually building something
from scratch live
in front of you
and then writing all
the code it makes
it do Internet Of Things
stuff, and then also follow up
with some silly demos of similar
things using the same recipe.
So first, electrical engineering
for web devs, first thing we're
going to talk about is signals.
So we build software, all
the stuff that makes up
our software is represented
by a couple of numbers, zeros
and ones.
At the end of the day, no matter
what complex data structure
you're using or you know
lambdas, all this stuff,
it boils down to zeros and
ones that are somewhere
in memory and through a CPU.
And we have something kind
of similar in the electrical
engineering domain.
We have zeros and
ones which are also
represented on our dev boards
As a high and low voltage.
In the case of a board
of five-volt logic,
like an Arduino
Uno, your one bit
is actually- they're actually
backwards on the slide--
the one bit is actually
the high, the five-volt,
and the low value is
zero-volt, also called ground.
And this is what we're
going to be moving around
to make a cool stuff happen.
And so we have a zero and a one.
So we have everything, right?
That's everything we need
in software to represent
any of that complex structure.
So we should be done, right?
No.
We actually need
some more stuff.
We need a couple more things
because the real world
is about physical things
like electrons moving around
and conductors and
all that stuff.
So there's a lot of hazy
zone, a lot more hazy zone
than you're probably
used to in software.
And one of the kind of
signals we're going to read
is an analog signal.
And this is everything between
that low state, that zero,
and that one.
And this comes up
a lot when you're
reading from sensors that
might be outputting stuff
as kind of a range.
And in the software
you end up reading
this is a ratio, a
ratio of your precision.
So on a zero to
1023 scale, you'd
be reading that as some number
between those boundaries.
That's great.
So now we have zeros and ones
and the stuff in the middle,
right?
So we should be set.
One more thing.
One more kind of
signal that we're
going to be dealing
with, that we're
going to be moving around.
And that is PWM, which is short
for the pulse width modulation,
which is a really big mouthful.
But what it really
means is analog output.
So the analog
signal on the top is
the thing we will read
from the outside world.
So a half value there'd
be like 2 and 1/2 volts.
That'd be halfway.
PWM works a little
bit different.
It is actually a really
big topic in itself.
I could probably come up
here and talk about it,
because people have written
whole books on this topic.
But essentially, it
is analog output.
And the difference is,
instead of outputting
2 and 1/2 volts,
what you do is you
output 2 and 1/2
volts on average.
So its average over time.
So you switch back and forth
between the low and high
to make up that kind
of analog signal.
And the specific reason is
it gets kind of complicated
but the TLDR is that motors
don't like half voltage.
So this is the workaround
we've developed.
We just go back and forth then
the motor will run about half
as fast.
It also works the same way
for light emitting diodes.
OK, so we talked about signals.
Let me show all
of you some stuff.
Let's do some show and tell.
We're going to talk
about the components.
Components are a lot like LEGOs
except sometimes they dance.
You can make them dance and
sometimes they catch on fire.
But they 're the
little things you're
going to take and put together
to build your project.
So I'm going to switch
on over to my handy dandy
little projector thingamajig.
I'm going to slide it over so
there's a little less shadow.
And I'm just going
to walk through some
of the different
components we're going
to use to build our stuff.
I'm going to start with
boards, because you
might as well start with the
most complicated thing first.
This is probably
familiar to most of you.
This is an Arduino Uno.
It is a microcontroller.
Well, just this part.
We'll talk about the
other part later.
So this is an Arduino Uno.
And it is a board for--
it's really good at reading
from the outside world.
It has a whole bunch of
pins on these little things
that you can plug sensors into.
And it's really, really robust
from an electrical engineering
standpoint.
You can do terrible
things to this
that would make other
kinds of electronics sad,
like accidentally plugging
something to the wrong place.
And it usually keeps
working so it's
very resistant to the
magic smoke problem.
And it has a few different
kinds of pins that I'm
going to point out now.
There's these kind
of special pins.
There one that says 5e
which is your reference one
and a ground which is
your reference zero.
It has some analog
inputs that we'll
use to read from analog sensors
which will come up soon.
And then it has a whole bunch
of these digital input output
pins.
And some of them have a
tilde in front of them
which just means
that you can use PWM.
They can be enabled
for PWM output.
That's great.
The Arduino is wonderful.
It can interact
with the sensors.
But has not a very fast
CPU as a result, which
means we can't do a lot
of the cool things we
want to do for IOT like
transport layer security
negotiations.
SSL HTTPS doesn't work
very well on this chip.
There are ways to do it, but
internet and all that stuff
is hard because this thing
doesn't have an operating
system.
We're actually writing code
on metal for the most part,
right on the CPU.
It doesn't have file
systems, not really,
not like we're used to.
It doesn't have virtual memory.
We're writing at
a much lower level
than we're comfortable with.
But it's great, so we can plug
in our components into this
and be happy.
The next part of the
recipe, or next component
I'd like to show you
is a Raspberry Pi.
Let me turn it so it is
facing the right way.
And this is a tiny
little computer.
Has a lot of the
same features you
find in a laptop or cellphone
or some other higher power
computer that you're
used to using.
And what's great about this is
you can run a real operating
system on it like
Linux, which gives you
that virtual memory, that
network stack, all that
cool stuff are used
to and that we've
become comfortable
with while we've been
building for web development.
And it has GPIO
pins up at the top.
So you can actually plug
components into it directly
and they're pretty powerful.
But I don't usually
recommend people use it
for their first project because
the Raspberry Pi is much less
robust than the Arduino.
It's a little bit more finicky
and a little bit more prone
to breaking if you accidentally
make it do something terrible.
So set that aside for now.
OK let's talk about some of
the more simple components.
The simplest component
you're probably
going to deal with while
building is a wire.
So I'm going to bring one out
and show you a little jumper
wire.
Jumper wires, we're going
to be using a lot of these.
What they do is we use
them to connect two things.
And what you can
use them to do is
to move those volts around,
move those electrons around
and that's kind
of the way you're
going to move your data around.
So there's a wire
which is great.
We can attach them
with soldering
but sometimes we don't
want to solder them,
like at the very
beginning of our project.
That's where this
comes in handy.
This is a breadboard.
I actually found a transparent
one which is awesome.
So how many of you
are familiar with
or have used breadboards before?
Almost everyone, but
a few people not.
I'm actually going to
explain how they work.
You can plug components
and wires into them
they have little like
kind of clamp things here.
And the way they work is
each one of these rows
here is connected.
So if we actually
flip it over we
can see each one of these
little sections is connected.
So it just clamps different
components together.
So you can play around
before you solder things.
It also has these of
rails on the side.
They go all the way up and down.
And this is by custom
used for power and ground,
to have that reference one
and reference zero handy.
And there's also a
trough in the middle
and that's just a
convention left over
from a certain size a microchip,
but a lot of components
are built to take
advantage of that trough.
And that is a breadboard
Breadboards are great while
you're building things
but eventually you're going to
want to actually take it out
into the world.
And if you take out a project
on a breadboard and shake it,
all of your components
fall off and you're sad.
That is why there are
these wonderful things that
are called perfboard, which
stands for perforated board.
It comes in lots
of different kinds
some which are actually just a
bunch of little pieces of metal
in a grid that you
connect with solder.
But they also have
kinds that look just
like tiny breadboards
which are my favorite
because I can just
take whatever design
I had on my mini-breadboard
and I can just copy it over.
And I don't have to think a lot
about evaluating that circuit
again which is great.
I love not thinking
about something
so I can think about my project.
One more kind of wiry component
is going to come up a lot.
This is a resistor.
A resistor is kind of like I'm
really terrible wire, which
you I think is useful
but as it turns out
is actually really,
really useful.
It comes up a lot.
We're going to be using them a
little further on in the talk.
They Come in a whole
bunch of different values.
You can actually learn the
color code and the band code.
But I tend to just keep
them in little bags that
describe what they are
so I don't have to,
because I don't like
thinking about things
I don't want to think about.
And there are a whole bunch of
different kinds of resistors.
And you can build very
sophisticated things with just
them.
But for the purpose of this
talk and your beginning project,
all you really need to know is
if there are 10k ohm resistors.
They exist.
And they're all you
really need for right now.
10k ohm.
OK, some more components.
This is a tiny button.
It is a push button.
It has two pins that
stick out of the side.
When you leave it alone no
data is moving across it.
So it's open in that case,
and when you push it down
to close it, when you
push the button field,
click the too little
wires are connected.
And it allows the electrons
to move from one side
to the other.
So we will be using that as
a very simple digital input.
Another simple digital device
is a light emitting diode.
Here is a nice yellow LED.
LEDs are little light bulbs.
If there is a 0 on one side
and a one on the other side
it turns on.
If the value is the same on
both sides it does not turn on.
It is directional.
So you have to have the one
on the side that's longer
and a zero on the side that
is shorter for it to turn on.
That's a really
wonderful digital output.
It's super simple.
And I mentioned analog and PWM.
So I'm going to show you
a couple other components.
This is what's called
a potentiometer.
It is a little dial.
And it has three pins on it.
And it's kind of cool
because you put reference one
on one side, five-volt, you
put ground on the other side.
And then the middle pin will
tell you how far along the dial
you've gone.
So it gives you an
analog input that you
can read from and do cool stuff
with like controlling analog
components like this servomotor.
And a servomotor is the
opposite of a potentiometer.
It has a little arm that moves.
Generally you don't want to play
with the motor off like this.
I want to show you.
It's also a three-pin device.
And if you give it a ground on
one side, voltage at the other,
and then a PWM
input in the middle,
it'll go to the ratio of that.
So you can actually do an
analog input on a potentiometer,
turn it and then make
a servomotor move
by converting that to
PWM and outputting it.
OK, so we did show and tell.
We talked about some components.
Let's go back to slides.
So I showed you
a bunch of stuff.
Now for the recipe.
That's the list of
ingredients we can pull from.
The recipe I use for the first
time a build a project is this.
I start with all
those components.
I figure out what
I want to build
and what components I need
to solve that problem.
If I need something to move
there might be servomotors,
LEGOs who knows?
There might be
sensors, wires, there
might be chips that do
something, IMUs, sensors,
motors maybe.
Once I have all my components
together, what I do
is I connect those two.
An Arduino Uno is
usually the first board
I will use because
like I said it's
great at handling the real world
and all that kind of quirks
of it.
And then I program that
Arduino with a special sketch,
a special program
called Firmata.
And Firmata allows me to plug
it into a Raspberry Pi over USB
and then offload all the work
of controlling the components.
That is great, because
now I can actually
control all those
components via the Arduino
from my real operating
system on the Raspberry Pi.
On the Raspberry
Pi I use Node.js,
and my favorite Node.js
library Johnny-Five.
You'll see why it's
awesome but is a Node.js
library for sending
Firmata signals
and controlling
those components.
Now this point we have a thing.
So we have JavaScript
running on our Raspberry Pi,
and it can move things around.
And we need last
ingredient, internet.
For this situation
I use Firebase.
So let's dig a little bit into
a couple of those components.
First, let's take a little
deeper look at Johnny-Five.
So I'm just going to web
search for Johnny-Five.
There's official documentation.
There's also the
older GitHub readme.
I'll make that a little bigger.
And it is awesome.
And I will tell you
why it's awesome.
There are actually
a lot of libraries
out there for doing
Firmata control, from node.
So I recommend that you
give them all a try.
But Johnny-Five's my favorite.
And the reason is because
it's documentation is amazing.
Not only does it
have a huge picture
of a robot doing that, which
is pretty cool, especially
if you remember the movie--
does anyone remember the movie?
OK.
But the cool part is
you scroll on down
and there's a list of
the different components
you might want in a system.
For example let's
say we want a button.
We want a button, OK.
So I don't really
need to know anything.
I just make my breadboard
look like that.
And then it will work.
And then accompanying
that diagram
is the code that makes
that diagram work.
So then I take this code
and I paste it into a file
and I node run it and
it's just working.
And the cool thing is you
can actually string together
a bunch of those things.
We might want more
than a button.
I can go find some
other sensor like I
don't know how about a LIDAR,
which stands for laser radar.
And I can copy that picture
again, change the pins
so none of them conflict
because I can remember numbers
to move around and then
I just paste this code
into the same program.
And I can build up a
very rough Hello world
all these components just by
copying and pasting and copying
pictures.
Which is awesome because
then I can think more
about the details of how
I want my thing to work
and how I want people to use it.
And that is why
Johnny-Five is awesome.
And there's just so many
components, LCDs, buttons,
motors, all sorts of
stuff, and all of them
have a very similar
format for documentation.
That's why Johnny-Five
is awesome.
Let's talk a little
bit about another one
of those, which is Firebase.
So one of the ways
that I look at Firebase
is it's kind of a bag of
goodies to make app dev easier.
And how many of you have
used Firebase before?
Ooh, a bunch of people, OK.
So Firebase is kind
of a bag of goodies.
It has a whole bunch
of different components
which you could
use independently
but fit very well together.
And it handles things like
synchronizing real time data,
handling network
disconnects, offline time,
and all that kind of stuff.
It also has static file
hosting because a lot of people
write Firebase apps that
just use JavaScript and HTML.
And it also handles whole bunch
of authentication helpers.
How many of you have
implemented OAuth before?
Was it fun?
No one ever says--
someone said yes,
but I don't know
if it was serious.
OAuth can be kind of a
little bit of a headache.
So Firebase has libraries it
make that a whole lot easier,
which is awesome.
But we're only going to talk
about one of those components
for this recipe, just
the Realtime Database.
And the Firebase
Realtime Database,
I kind of as a big ball
of JSON in the sky.
So if I can take all the
data I need for my project,
whether it be mobile
app or an IT project,
and if I can represent
it as a hierarchical data
structure, JSON, then
I can stick it up
in Firebase using the
sieve and push methods.
And then my devices or my
apps that work with my devices
can choose to listen
to-- you can subscribe
to either nodes, subtrees,
queries against subtrees--
and what will happen is
Firebase will automatically
make call backs on my
mobile app other code
that relates to my IOT device.
That makes it so much
easier, which is awesome.
I can tell you more about
it but why don't we actually
just look at some of the
Firebase stuff in action.
So, oh no, its freaking
out a little bit.
Let me reload that.
It doesn't like being in a tab.
All the events replay.
So here's an example.
These are the Muni buses.
Has anyone taken
a bus or a subway
since they've been
in San Francisco?
Since they came in?
So was it on time?
This is an example
of real time data
that you care about
being real time.
Where are your buses right now?
You don't care where the
bus was two hours ago
or where it was
yesterday or aggregated
data from a long time ago.
If you're sitting at a
bus stop and your cold,
you care about where
the bus is right now
and why isn't it where you are.
And here are actually all of the
Muni buses, The Municipal Bus
System in San Francisco
right around us.
In this is where they actually
are as of 100 milliseconds ago.
Being San Francisco, you
can tell that most of them
are stopped.
This is real data.
The examples real, the
buses are just not moving,
probably because it's
getting on into rush hour.
One game I like to play
is looking for clusters
of buses that are the same.
How many fives can I find
right next to each other?
So that's where they are,
they're all having a party.
So here's one other
example of real time data,
which is real time
collaboration like collaborating
on Google Docs comments.
I'm going to take
a little risk here.
This is an interactive slide.
You can pull out your
mobile device or laptop.
If you go to a
firesketch.firebaseapp.com,
we can draw dinosaur together.
I'm going to start and if anyone
to join in, someone's helping.
Who's helping?
Is it fast?
Cool.
OK, so I see a lot of
people are joining in.
Thank you for being nice.
This is a risk to have
people draw on stage.
You never know what can happen.
So switching back to
my Keynote slides.
So that's just a couple examples
of what real time data is,
why it's cool, and I guess you
can kind of get an idea of how
it relates to IOT projects.
We often care about
if we hit the button
we want the lights to turn
off now, not in an hour.
So here's some of
the code that you use
to interactive with Firebase.
If you want to
write to Firebase,
the first thing you do is
you connect to Firebase.
You connect to Firebase by just
installing the client library,
and then just
attaching to Firebase.
All Firebases are
identified by a URL.
And all locations in
them are also URLs.
You can just use path segments
to work your way down that JSON
block.
If you want to write data, we
have a few different methods
but simplest is set.
You take you reference
to a location in Firebase
and you call set.
And then you pass it,
text, numbers, JSON,
anything that can be in JSON,
including another JSON tree.
When you want to read data,
this is the part that gets cool,
you just add attach
a listener, just
like you'd attach a listener
to a button on a web page,
except this is a
listener to the internet.
And when that location or
that query changes then
Firebase will automatically
call your code.
And what's cool about this
kind of really simple interface
is it the Firebase client
libraries handle local caching,
they handle threading, all that
stuff that's kind of a pain
sometimes.
It also handles things like
going between online offline
states.
Let's build some stuff.
So now we have all recipe
components ready to go.
Let's actually build something.
And we are going to build
Hello World of electronics.
How does that sound?
Does anyone know what Hello
World of electronics is?
It is a blinky light.
Yes we are going
to have a button
and we're going to have an LED.
And when we hit
the button, we're
going to make the LED turn on,
but with one special twist,
we're going to be sending
data through the internet
to do that, because why not?
So like I said, I'm just
going to copy what Johnny-Five
shows in that picture.
So I'm going to go over to
Johnny-Five, because this is
the easiest way to live code.
You just have it pre-done
and copy and paste.
So we're going to
go over to button.
And what does button have?
The first thing button has
is it has some wires moving
across and then a button.
So I'm just going to drag
that down into the corner
so you can see a reference.
I'll just leave this
up for full screen.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
get to jumper wires
and we're going to move that
reference zero and reference
one over.
So there's little
ground pin here.
I'm going to stick a blue cable
in that and copy it over--
with the -- over to
the little minus rail.
Then I'm going to take
the five-volt which
is our reference
one and we're going
to use the wire to send it over
to the little red rail which
is unlike the picture.
The picture is backward
for some reason,
I decided blue should be on.
But in any case, the next
thing we're going to do
is we're going to
take our button
and stick it into
the breadboard.
This is a regular
push button that I've
put some feet on so that
it actually connects
to the breadboard well.
And we're going to
grab some jumper wires.
And the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
use purple wire
and we're going to make
one pin on the red.
We're going to connect the red
side to one of the button pins.
And then we're going to
connect the other one
to one of the digital reads.
We could use any of them.
So I will use a
red wire and we're
going to read from pin four.
Four sounds good.
So now what will happen
is that we have a button.
It looks like it should
work at this point,
because we hit
the button, right?
And then it copies
that five-volt, that
reference one over to have pin.
And it should be great.
But there is actually
something extra in this.
There was a resistor there
which went to the ground.
This is where that real
world physics stuff comes in.
This is the case where you
might need an awful wire,
because our button copies data
but only when the button is
pushed, when it's open.
So when the button is
pushed, everything is fine.
The five-volt is coming across.
It's going across and it's
getting sent over to- oh
that jumper wire broke.
I'll replace it-- it
sends it over to the input
and we read it.
But when we let go it opens
up and it's no longer moving
any state, which is
bad because we have
some trapped electrons
that are hanging
out there causing trouble.
And how that will
manifest in your project
is you're going to see the
thing kind of bounce back
and forth between one and zero
which is no fun because it's
confusing.
OK so that's fixed.
So what we're going
to do is we're going
to use a pull down resistor.
That's what it's called.
So we're going to plug it into
the side we're reading from
and then we're going to
put that into the ground.
And what this
pull-down resistor does
is if the button is pressed
it doesn't do anything.
The reference one
still gets copied.
And then the input
reads it and its fine.
But when you let go it
drains out that excess charge
and makes our circuits work.
It pulls it back down to zero.
So we have a very
simple circuit.
Let's do some live
coding now and by that
I mean copy and paste.
So I'm going to grab all this.
I'm going to open
up my terminal.
I'm going to open up vi,
is the only text editor
IDE the world will ever need,
and paste in off the internet.
Let's delete some
of this extra stuff.
There's a lot of stuff in
here we don't actually need.
There's are some REPL
stuff which we're not
going to be using that.
And we have a very
simple program now.
Well before we
can use it we have
to-- there'll be a true test
of the conference Wi-Fi,
live installing.
Yes, because it was
an empty directory
before I started as you can see.
OK, so it installed, yeah.
And here's our program.
I didn't actually
change anything.
I should probably
change the pin number.
We actually plugged it
into, what was it, pin four.
Let's change that
from two to four.
And run Node.js, oh, I
hadn't plugged it in.
Plugging it in would
help, with a USB cable.
Oh yes so one thing
you're seeing here
is I'm actually plugging into
my laptop instead of a Raspberry
Pi, and that's because
as I mentioned,
a Raspberry Pi is very
similar to a small computer.
So while your doing
development you
can use your computer
instead, which is great,
because it works a
lot better because it
has a keyboard on it and stuff.
And then later when you
want to actually take it out
in the world you can copy your
program to the Raspberry Pi
and everything is happy.
OK, so we should see something.
When we hit the button
down it should say down,
and we're let go,
it should say up.
So we have our Hello
World in terms of we
have a button that
goes up and down.
Yeah!
Let's go copy in
another part of that.
We want to have a little LED
that turns on and off when
we hit the button.
So let's go ahead and do that.
And then we will
refactor internet
into it, the best
kind of refactoring.
So we're going to search the
page for the thing we want.
We want a LED.
I'm going to go over to LED.
And it says take an LED.
And I'm going to grab one.
I'm going to grab a
little yellow LED.
And their circuit
diagram is very simple.
They're just plugging
it into the board.
I'm just going to move
that over to the breadboard
and then we're going
to copy this code.
So what I'm doing is I'm
remembering which pin is long,
because that's one
that has to be warm,
it has to go to
the high voltage.
Then I'm going to
take the reference
low from that
little rail and I'm
going to connect it
with a jumper wire.
And then I'm going to use
one of the digital inputs,
or one of the digital
outputs from the Arduino
to make the LED light up or dim.
I'll grab a brown wire again.
There should be more colors.
And we'll use pin 12.
So now, if pin 12 is set
too high state, to one,
we're going to have
a one on one side
and we have zero
that's already there,
and the LED will turn on.
If it is not, the
LED will stay off
because there will be
a zero on both sides,
and no charge will move.
And no LED will turn on.
So let's go ahead and
this one is pretty simple.
We just borrow an LED.
Let's go back over to our
awesome, awesome text editor.
We're going to make an LED.
And it was on 13 in the
diagram but we changed it to 12
because we like
living on the edge.
And to turn it on and off,
on and LED got on and off.
So when we push it down,
the LED will turn on,
and when we pick it up,
the LED will turn off.
So we'll run that code, then
that little thing there,
shrink this a little
bit, thank you.
Now our program is running.
So when we hit the button
The LED turns on, yeah.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
So now we've pretty
much finished
the thing part of our Internet
Of Things Hello World.
Let's add some internet.
This is a great point to kind
of take a breath when you're
building something,
because now you probably
don't have to move around
too much of the electronics,
and you can switch
back to web dev mode
or put our JavaScript
hacker hat on.
So we're going to add internet.
And I said we do Firebase.
So let's add some Firebase.
I'm going to go to
firebase.com because I'm
going to continue the live
code by copying and pasting.
I'm just going to go and copy
stuff out of the Quickstart.
So we're doing the internet.
We're building for the
Internet Of Things.
But we're going to go
to the Web Quickstart
because it's the one with
the JavaScript in it,
because we're using Node.js.
The first thing we're going to
have to do is install Firebase.
That was fast.
That was awesome.
We're going to have
to get the Firebase
and see if the copy
thing works today.
And the next thing
we're going to do
is just kind of walk through it.
So now if we have the
Firebase client there.
We're going to connect
to our Firebase.
Which we're going to do
right around the place
where we instantiate
those buttons.
We'll change it to
firebutton.firebaseio.com
And then I'm going
to do a little trick.
As you just add dash demo to
the end of a Firebase domain,
it becomes a demo Firebase,
which means you don't even
need an account to create it.
But please don't launch
production apps on it,
your data's going to
get deleted at random
because it's for demos.
Then I'm going to
put a path on there
just in case I want to use
that demo Firebase for more
things like many buttons.
And we're going to
go to this location.
One cool thing about
Firebase is if you
want to see what's in
there in your web browser,
we can just drop it in
there and we can see it
in this Firebase console.
I'm going to remove that node.
It's going to take a look
at the whole Firebase.
I just cleared stuff
out because I practiced.
So there was data
in there all ready.
Now it's empty, like you got
to it for real the first time.
Then the next thing we're going
to do is what we want to do
is we want to write that
button state to the internet.
So we're going to go
right here to writing
data which is very
conveniently the next step
in the Quickstart.
What are the odds of that?
So we are not
writing complex JSON
we're going to write
something very simple.
We're just going to
write down when it's down
and we're going to write
up when it goes up.
So we're going to write
that state to the Firebase.
So now we have a
write-only button.
Let's give it a kick
and see if it works.
So we have our
little program there.
We're going to split the screen
more times, because why not?
We have our little
Firebase viewer here.
We have our button up there.
I started up the Node script.
Let's see what happens
when we hit the button.
So we hit the button and
then when we press it down
it writes down and up to the
Firebase out on the internet.
So now we have made the
very, very minimal Internet
Of Things.
We have a thing that changes
the internet when you touch it.
Yeah!
But that's not quite
what we want to get.
We wanted to turn the LED on
and off via the internet, right?
So rather than turn
it on and off here,
why don't we read from
Firebase to turn it on and off?
So we're going to go back
on over to the Quickstart.
We're going to go to the
next step of reading data.
It's like this is rehearsed.
And we're going to paste
into the reading data step.
And we don't want to
do an alert, though.
We also don't want
to read these things.
So this goes into
another subpath.
We just want to
read a reference.
And here I've got
Firebase callback.
So the way it works is I
give it a function that
will get called whenever the
value changes at that location.
And it's going to send me
a snapshot which contains
a whole bunch of metadata.
It's like an immutable
representation
of the state of the data
the time it got called.
All we really want is
the value because this
is a silly project.
So we have our button state.
We want to do if down.
If the button is down,
turn the LED on, else.
So what this does is
whenever the state
of the button in
Firebase changes
this function will get called.
I have a-- why is it
outside the-- oh yeah I do.
Live coding with audience help.
It's like pair-programming
but crazy more.
OK, so when the
button goes down,
this will get called
whenever the state changes.
And then I'll just
extract the value
and then I'll just
do a statement on it.
Let's see if it works.
So I have my Firebase
viewer over here.
I'll bring that back
down so we can see.
I have the camera
and the button, OK.
And it's running.
So I hit the button down
it changes the internet.
And then the internet
changes the thing.
So now we've made the full loop.
And what's kind of cool is
I can go to the internet
and I can just
change it directly
all hacker like, and it changes
the thing from our web browser.
[APPLAUSE]
So we have now done our
Hello World minimal Internet
Of Things thing.
That means it is time
for silly demos, right?
Let's do some silly demos.
This code very saw,
we built something,
OK, silly demos,
sillier than even this
because-- let me turn you
my Firebase back to up.
The LED turned off.
Where was my-- there we go.
So silly demos, One
thing that's kind of cool
is if you take a
multiple of these things
and you combine them.
So I have maybe prepared
like a cooking show,
another one of these up here.
I can actually use
it like a telegraph,
like the most overly complicated
silly telegraph ever made,
which is great.
If someone wants to press
it from the audience
you can press that
every once in while.
We can actually communicate
in Morse code, which is cool
because we're going
through a server in Texas
right now, which is awesome.
We're actually on two
different Wi-Fi networks.
That is actually on a
cellular phone tether
and this is actually
on the conference Wi-Fi
and it's still really
fast, which is really cool.
And you can do more
things with this.
You can interact with anything
that supports a Firebase
client like my slide deck.
So if someone would
hit the button
you can do things like
hopefully Rickroll my slides.
But it did not
seem to work today.
Rick did not want to come out.
Oh there it goes, it took
a little while to load.
So you can do
things like Rickroll
your slide deck from the
internet, which is awesome.
And here's another example
of something you can do,
another silly demo.
Remember those potentiometers?
I grabbed a couple
and I'm like, "What's
the simplest thing I can
build with a potentiometer?"
I built an Etch a Sketch.
So I can actually draw on my
little JavaScript white board.
And what's cool about this is I
think this is 60 lines of code
and that white board is
under 100 lines of code also.
So these are things you
can seriously hack out
in under an hour, which is
great because once you build
your thing, you can go take
it into the world, put it
in somebody's
hands, and then you
can start to do user
testing and find out
the viability of your project
before you have someone crank
out 1,000 PCBs for you,
which costs money and is
hard to undo.
OK, so we have some silly demos.
So some parting words while
people play with the button.
First of all, wasn't that easy?
Was that easier than
you thought it would be?
OK, that's what I like to
hear, because this stuff should
be easy and it should be fun.
And this is the most fun
way I've found to do it.
The other piece of advice
is there's always new boards
and new cool things coming out.
And one thing I found that
helps me a lot to kind of focus
and actually get products done
is I let the projects guide me.
So when a new board comes
out, I'll note that it's there
and I'll wait to buy it later.
So it doesn't sit there
I myself and gather dust.
Instead, I think
of a cool project
I want to build, like
an Etch a Sketch,
and then I make a shopping
list and let that guide me.
I let that determine which
board I'm going to use.
When in doubt, I
usually use boards
I already have lying
around, because rarely
do you need the newest,
shiniest, fastest board,
especially for
projects like these.
The next thing I like
to encourage you to do
is experiment.
Do silly things, try them
out especially if you
have the parts lying around.
Just throw them together
and see what happens.
And don't be too afraid
about things breaking
or about things
catching on fire, which
is kind of into the next one.
While you do this
kind of hacking things
are going to break.
You are going to discover the
magic blue smoke it that when
it comes out stuff
stops working.
It doesn't go back in.
Celebrate that.
It's going to happen.
It's OK.
Learn from it.
And try not to burn up your
next board the same way.
As it turns out motors, when
they spin they generate power.
Whoah, I didn't ever think
of that, but it makes sense.
Now I need a new board.
That's OK.
Oh yeah, finally now,
google cool stuff.
And almost all of you have at
least one board to play with.
So go build some cool
stuff and tell us about it.
Show it to us.
Get out there on the
internet and they
share the things you're
building, because it's
such a great community of makers
right now which is so much fun.
It's a great time to do this.
So thank you.
That's it.
And now we have almost over
15 minutes for questions.
There are actually mics around
if you're present and would
like to ask a questions.
Otherwise, I'm going to
open the floor to questions.
No questions from anyone?
There's a question.
So the question
was about where I
buy my stuff, my
sensors, my components,
and all that kind of stuff.
There's a whole bunch
out there like DFRobot.
But I think my favorite
one is Adafruit.
Adafruit.com is awesome
because not only do they
make great stuff but like
Johnny-Five, the documentation
is awesome.
They have this whole Adafruit
learning system and tons
of other social media
and videos out there
that help you build
all this stuff
and make it a lot less
intimidating than reading
spec sheets.
Although they have
the datasheets, too.
They're actually very good about
linking to those docs, too.
So they make it easy and
fun which is awesome.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
First one is, looking
at the simple schematic
you had with the pull to
ground and so forth, I
spent an hour not knowing that.
For those of us who
aren't EEs where can we
learn easy simple stuff like
that that we need to know
to make these simple circuits?
JEN TONG: So where can you
learn the minimal amount
of electrical
engineering to get by?
Honestly the best
place I've found
is the Johnny-Five
documentation.
So I either find the
Johnny-Five documentation
or if it's something
more sophisticated--
Adafruit with their
components there
are a lot of tutorials
that go along with them.
They go into great detail.
I'm like, "Why do
you need to put
a capacitor across
power and ground
on your big LED projects?"
And they explain
this in great detail
and they back it up with videos.
Beyond that, if
you're doing something
more esoteric or a
little more challenging
where you need to go a little
deeper into stuff, YouTube,
because you actually see
people putting it together
under the camera,
which is a long way.
It's a lot more than just
pictures or schematics.
They usually explain it while
they're building it, too.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
is this is great to see
with Arduinos and Raspberry
Pis and all of these components.
What about the components that
we have in our tool boxes?
What about what
about our Edison,
what about Brillo and Weave?
How do we map what you just
showed us to all of that?
JEN TONG: Great question.
One thing that's really
cool about Johnny-Five's
architecture is they
decoupled all the board
logic from the abstracted
center interfaces.
That means if I go to
the official Johnny-Five
documentation, which is
now on johnny-five.io,
which is pretty, you can see
pictures of all the boards it
works with.
And I'm pretty sure
the Edison is in there.
There it is.
There's the Edison.
And so a lot different
boards are in there.
I'm not sure the
other one is in there
because I forgot what the
name of the other board was.
But I'm not as familiar
with that board.
So I'll leave that as an
exercise to all of you.
DragonBoard?
I don't know if it's in there.
I can't search the
page with text.
But look around and if
Johnny-Five does not work,
I can guarantee you
there's some other Firmata
library that works.
Every time I've
looked, like "I wonder
if there's a Firmata
library for Ruby that
has good community support."
And there's always
more than one option,
which is great
because then I can
program in Ruby build the stuff
which is fun sometimes, too.
Any other questions?
I see one.
How come when you
plugged in the LED
it didn't short
without the resistor,
because you connected
it straight to ground?
Wouldn't there be too
much current which
would destroy the LED bulb?
JEN TONG: So the question was,
why did the LED not get angry?
I put five volts across the
LED and I kind of did a trick
because now LEDs come
in different colors,
as one of the kind of
the nasty complexities,
is different colors be they
yellow or red or blue or green,
have different
ranges of voltages
they're willing to accept.
And one pitfall,
just the prevent you
from your first fire
incident, is five volts
Arduino Uno and a red volt LED
do not get along like that.
The red one will
light up briefly
and then will never
light up again.
That's because the maximum
voltage is less than five.
So what you can do is you
can take that resistor
and you just put them
in line together.
So you connect, for
example, the LED
to ground or to the digital
pin with a resistor in line.
I use a yellow LED because
it will accept five volts
without catching on fire.
And it was easier
to do for the talk.
But great question.
Yes, the components all
have their own little quirks
and things as simple as color
can actually change a lot.
AUDIENCE: One more
question, you say
that the fan
generates power, does
that have any effect
on your circuit?
JEN TONG: So I briefly
mentioned that one
of the ways I discovered,
when I blew up a board, was I
plugged a motor
directly into it.
And the motor was small enough
so the current draw didn't
burn out the board,
which can also do it.
That is why you usually
want to use a transistor
to move a motor.
But what happened is that
the motor was spinning
and there was a
load on the motor.
So when I stopped sending
electricity to the motor,
the motor kept spinning.
And so it's called I think
phantom power or something
like that.
What happened is when
a motor is spinning
and it doesn't have
electricity coming
in it becomes a generator.
So it started feeding
electricity back into my pins
and then it burned out my
board, which I've actually done
on Arduino before just to see
if it would burn it up and it
actually didn't.
The Arduino Uno did fine even
with tiny motor's spinning
which was cool.
It's like, "I'm going to
try and break this thing.
I can't.
Yeah."
But that's just something
else to be aware of.
You can use transistors
or you can use a diode.
The diagrams all
over the internet
will give you that
particular tip.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to make
that work without the Raspberry
Pi and use a Wi-Fi
shield or something?
JEN TONG: Is it
possible to do this
with cutting the Raspberry Pi
out and just doing an Arduino
shield?
And the answer is kind
of, so technically yes.
You can build all this
whole thing only in Arduino
and there are libraries
to do the Wi-Fi.
You might need a
more powerful Arduino
to do the TLS negotiation
before it times out.
You can technically do
it, but like I said,
when you're coding
right on metal
you lose things that
you're used to having
like an internet stack.
So you're actually building
the packets by hand each time,
whether you're doing it
or a library is doing it.
You also don't really
have threading.
So you have to wait for that
data to come on the wire.
So, you end up diving way too
deep into protocols and way
too deep on the low level stuff.
Why do that?
Operating systems already
solved that a long time ago.
Take advantage of those.
Then later, this is great for
building one of something,
but when you go into production
and you're Kickstarter-funded,
and you're super-successful,
and you need to build 1,000,
that's when you worry
about that part,
because then you can save
tons of power and stuff
and it's awesome.
So one more question
coming around.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned some word
that I didn't hear in regards
to Johnny-Five like chroma
language or something.
So what is Johnny-Five and
what is the name of its Ruby
counterpart that you mentioned?
JEN TONG: A Ruby counterpart?
Yes so there are a whole bunch
of different Firmata libraries
you can actually use web
search for a Firmata library.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
what word you're saying.
JEN TONG: Firmata.
This is the word called Firmata.
I'll just show you
Firmata real quick.
We actually have
time to show you.
So when I first started
doing electronics
and I wanted to do a computer
attached to an Arduino,
I was like "I'm going
to build this protocol
language for moving
this stuff around
so I can just control it from
a higher level programming
language on the computer side."
And then I did some searching
I started building it,
and about halfway through I
realized that not only had it
already been written,
but it is packaged
with the Arduino thing.
So the Arduino IDE has a section
under samples called Firmata.
And there are a whole bunch
of different Firmatas.
The standard Firmata
is the standard one.
And you open it up
and it's a sketch.
And it's a very
mature protocol that's
been around for a long time.
It's very polished, super-easy
to understand, and super-easy
to extend.
And you can just flash
your board with it.
It's uploading right now.
And it's not working because
Johnny-Five is still running.
Yeah, and so once you get
Firmata on your board, which
you can just use the
Arduino IDE to do,
then you can go find a library.
You just search for
language and Firmata.
And Arduino Firmata on Ruby.
It's another beautiful library
that I've used a little bit
and it worked really well.
And what's cool is you
can go back to Johnny-Five
and use their pictures and then
just translate the code over
to the other libraries.
Yes, Firmata is the word.
Any other questions?
OK.
Well, if you ever
have any questions
or you want to show
me something cool,
feel free to grab
me or tweet at me
or whatever whenever you see me.
I'm around sometimes.
I'd love to see what you
all are up to, and thanks
for coming to my talk.